news daily from science mission
controversy over the role of cellular
prion protein in epilepsy has been laid
to rest in a paper published in
scientific reports authors develop few
mouse models using different backgrounds
and show that prion protein plays a role
in neuroprotection in chi nei treated
cells and mice for this function plant
protein should contain the amino acid 32
293 region and needs to be linked to the
membrane next the scientists in the
journal Nature communications identified
the blockbuster antacid lansoprazole
non-commercially as prevacid as a
potential anti-tuberculosis medication
the human cells convert Lance of
resorting to sulfur containing
metabolites lansoprazole sulfide which
kills the bacterium this metabolite
targets an enzyme called cytochrome bc1
complex that is crucial for the
bacterium to produce energy thereby
killing it off but it is past the human
potassium hydrogen ATP's for more news
visitors at www science mission comp our
science mission facebook page thanks for
watch